What is it?
Oh, it's a board with different feelings on it.
You know, happy, sad, irritated...
...and then I put pictures of all of us from around the office...
...so that we could show each other how we're feeling.
Great.
Why am I on "worthless"?
Let's see, my face is on "happy."
So, where do you want to put yours?
You can change it.
Do you have one that says "bored" of this conversation?
Oh, you do.
I'm moving mine to "sad" now.
So, that report that I wanted you to do...
Oh! Hey James, do you want to see my feelings board?
I just made it.
Wendy, I have important things to do.
I'm too busy to make your feelings.
Feel good.
It's okay, I'm sure he'll feel bad about it later.
In that case, I will put him on "guilty."
Hey, I'm so sorry about what I said earlier.
That was just... Hey, here.
Please take my credit card.
Buy yourself something nice.
It's the least I can do.
We should move him to "awkward."
That was really weird.
Yeah, it was.
What do you think his credit limit is?